and now let's shift to what biden is
doing because he knows he's sort of on
borrowed time but every now and again he
has to pretend that he's really he's
really tough so first off uh he did not
say anything about the brett kavanaugh
situation he's been questioned many
times by the media they you know usually
they just rush the media out
but he did not say anything about it at
all here's a generic one from biden just
about what he wants to do to his uh
political opponents you know
i have to admit to you
a lot of us elected officials have been
in office for a while
every once in a while something you
learn makes you viscerally angry
like if you had the person in front of
you'd want to pop them
no i really mean it
oh no i really mean it i'd want to pop
them now that's interesting considering
all the gun violence we've had for a
while popham now he was going like this
so i think he meant punch him
but uh he wants to punch his political
opponents or maybe pop them that's what
joe biden wants to do and no i really
mean it no i really mean it it's not one
of the usual nonsensical things that i
say i really want to punch or shoot
these people
that's joe biden uh but he basically
spent his weekend covering his butt for
all of the bad stuff that we see out
there inflation gas supply chain all of
the rest of it uh jackie toeitz on
twitter
had some interesting info on what's
going on with the economy right now
inflation just hit a new 40-year high
the overall cpi is up 8.6 since last
year gas is up almost 49 fuel 106
meat poultry and fish 13
milk 16 eggs 32 percent coffee 15
used cars 16 airline fare 38
real average
hourly earnings down
three percent so the thing is a freaking
disaster and i would argue this is the
greatest gift that he could hand aoc
because by governing so uh completely
incompetently uh it will fuel their base
to say oh see we had sort of this not
fully woke progressive this old guy and
he had something to do with obama and
whatever but look he wrecked everything
so we need someone even more radical and
someone even more into socialism and
someone more into big government so she
is going to stab you joe i'm not here to
do you any favors but if any of your
people are watching this the
progressives are coming to destroy you
fool
um
now uh there's more from joe's trip to
l.a that that video we just showed you
that was in los angeles the dystopian
nightmare where i used to live of los
angeles i will put five dollars in the
jar to kick somebody out of florida and
send them to california that's the new
plan with this money uh they asked biden
what he's doing about uh all of these
problems and you're not gonna believe it
but he found somebody else to blame well
he's labored from forehead to the tip of
his toes he used to run the laborers out
union look folks um today i'd like to
speak about my top economic priority
fighting inflation
i understand americans are anxious and
the anxious a good reason
i was raised in a household when the
price of gasoline rose precipitously it
was the discussion at the table it made
a difference when food prices went up
but we've never seen anything like
putin's tax on both food and gas
all right so first usually you know you
get the rambling right you just get the
little litter what's he saying you don't
really know and then of course it has
nothing to do with printing all of the
money it has nothing to do with all of
their bad economic policies this is
putin's price act now let's pretend for
a second that there's some legitimacy to
that that there is this war between
russia and ukraine and that because of
the resources and the oil and all of
those things that we live in this global
world now and when wars break out
especially with a big country that has a
lot of resources like russia that it can
affect the economies of other countries
let's say that's roughly true because
there's obviously some truth to that
isn't it the job of the presidents and
the prime ministers of the other
countries to figure out how to
compensate for that like if one guy if
if putin can invade ukraine and know
that he can disrupt the entire world
economy wouldn't it be your job as the
president of another country say the
united states of america to have some
firewalls in place to have some policies
perhaps in place
that would stop
uh our economy from tanking during that
i think that's what it would be but
that's not exactly what he's doing here
uh also he's just sort of incoherently
saying that exxon mobil is marking up
their prices for profit i don't know
that that's even true but also i
wouldn't i don't blame oil companies for
making money i don't blame anyone from
for making money uh maybe i guess
there's some level of some argument okay
maybe they're making too much money
right now or something like that i'm not
even sure that that's actually a legit
argument but again that that's not why
the economy is tanking it's tanking
because you guys are borrowing like
crazy people you're spending like crazy
people and you're printing money like
crazy people that's really the problem
it isn't just that when uh putin goes
into ukraine that exxon is like now
we'll stick it to the people like that's
just
not how it works they're making money
exxon's making money because their stock
is going up but okay let's move on uh
here is uh we're going to keep me on the
screen for this one here's biden with
some more wizardry
we're going to make sure that everybody
knows exxon's prophecy why don't you
tell them what exxon's profits were this
year this quarter
exxon made more money than god this year
wow
god better get a new account exxon made
more money than god
good god this man's an idiot this man is
an absolute idiot